we are we're moving into graphi now
you've done lots of graphing throughout
your arm many years in high school
and so this is going to draw on I mean
in the same way as arithmetic did a lot
of skills you already have however just
a bit of a warning when you first met
hammer let's just speak for a second cut
me out what kinds of functions or or
types of shapes basically do you know
how to graph when you're just thinking
on the Cartesian plane start off really
easy straight lines I can't way to go
through them cubics okay so all of those
are in the family of polynomials okay
you know how to draw anything else
if you draw a hyperbola okay so that's
one on X and all its you know
derivatives which is not a lot of
polynomial but three sigma did you know
how to grab all the stuff circles very
good so they don't even functions
anymore on it but there were they called
sanam pickled relations or relationships
right we've got exponential function
it's very good we got most of that
categories okay yeah all right so you
with all of those tools we got the
opportunity the luxury as it were to
treat each of those is like he's a big
category on grass and it's like well we
we met like sign in lucky 10 and we
spent a whole time just graphing down
and then like parabolas and locusts what
you've been doing more recently let's
just spend all that time doing that
now that you're in the complex plane we
treat you like extension to students and
so we're like okay look you know how to
do something you know that interpret
this right we're going to give you all
the different kinds of grasses or any
for measurement and a small number that
you aren't really really but we're just
going to give it to you altogether we're
not going to say okay all parabolas
today guys you're gonna get like at
least it's from pretty much every graph
I'm gonna show it to you it's a
different kind of function formulation
so quickly before we get into a complex
plane when you see a sentence like this
what does it mean how do you interpret
because like just look at that per
second this is another language this is
literally another language right like
what we mean by graph and what we mean
by all of this is very you know subject
specific language so if you were to try
and translate this without what using
the minimum number of like mathematical
words in notation how would you do it
trying to grease okay true but again but
that's quite specific it's like what
what do those even me how do I do a
seducer all online
I can't alright so there's going to be
like some sort of connected set of dots
which will form a line okay now when you
see this right all of the dots that you
have the reason why you get this set of
dots right and not like say this set of
dots or this set of dots or all these
other kinds of music it's because all
the dots you choose are going to
together obey this relationship that's
what it really means
okay so just alongside huge that's going
to be very important to do to the
complex plane here's my translation of
that sentence okay
when you take graph doesn't run right
what should be is draw the points or
plot the points
whose x and y like that's what these are
right they have values their x and
y-coordinates obey this equation like
they actually make the equation true
okay I suppose you could say satisfy
that would be a more mathematical way
okay
that's what it really means and that's
why for example if you pour it to put in
like zero one x equals zero black was
one that pair of numbers that order pair
does not obey this rule it doesn't fit
right so that's why you don't draw but
if I said to you okay half at zero six
zero six does have a bit so it's like
I'm gonna put a point on it then I'm
just gonna keep on doing it and of
course that's a very laborious way to do
things which is why we learn tools like
I can't find the roots and then
recognize that they are all shape with
this and then off you go okay so now
therefore if I gave you a sentence like
this
okay now the language is ever so
slightly changed but thinking about what
this needs
and then for think about what the
parallel here it is okay I'll give you
the easy bit I'm still gonna be drawing
right so this also means draw but now
these points they don't represent X&Y
like just random pair of real numbers
okay what you're drawing is actually a
set of complex numbers we just happen to
represent them with points okay
by the way what was the other main way
that we used to visually represent
complex numbers not as points but as yes
vectors so you've got magnitude
direction okay so I could draw them as
vectors but for now I'm just interested
in the past points I want to draw the
complex numbers who's now x and y right
there's no X or Y here okay but on the
complex plane we can use X&Y to
represent what do next might represent
forego the real and imaginary parts
right so I want to draw all the complex
numbers whose real and imaginary parts
and now the rest of it is just the same
that's just an equation that says I want
the real imaginary parts to do such and
such a thing
okay so satisfy this different way
okay now underneath where you've written
this black translation right I want you
to understand it you're gonna approach
this in one of two ways and you're gonna
need to be able to understand both and
master both because it's you need
different techniques for different kinds
of questions so you can do this either
with algebra think back to when we did
complex arithmetic and we said okay look
this thing here I can treat this as a
purely algebraic object and then work
with that so I can do it either
algebraically Oh
we recognize that complex numbers are
more than just algebra X's Y's we can
think of these as visual objects right
so I could do it geometrically
now looking at this question right
looking at what the question is asking
you to do if you had a choice all the
other things be equal which of these
would you prefer to do if I know that
could be I think we would prefer
geometrically but what you trying to
draw this thing you want a picture right
all the picture is the language of
geometry spit okay so if you possibly
can what you want to do is think about
this thing in terms of geometry if you
have no other choice like I don't know
what this is remotely then you do an
algebraic so let's do this as an example
what does what do those cook like some
numbers do when you put absolute value
judgment what we call that starts with
an M this is the watchlist right and the
modulus right so I translate this as the
modulus or Z whatever that complex
number happens to be the modulus is ed
is always that number right let's push
on this little bit more how do we define
the module see it would that be distance
from the origin right very good
so there's a whole bunch of Zins there's
a whole bunch of complex numbers that
are 5 units away from the origin right
there's a whole bunch of them in fact
there's an infinite set of this if you
were to plot every single one what shape
would they trace out a circle right so
let's draw this
okay so here's my circle and you can see
it's centered on the origin because
that's what I'm measuring from I've
drawn this but come on give me a bit
more detail this can be any circle right
now so what would you like me to write
on there okay I'm gonna have some real
sorry you're on the wait that's good
I got my real and my imaginary axes in
the right spots and what else remove it
I should have some v right v and they're
the center that's pretty points boy
there's a great question so here's the
funny thing right
if I were describing a point like if I
were describing that point there I would
call it 5i right that's where the point
is because we're good it is it's off the
real axis right so five there number as
a number is on the real axis only and
this is not there okay but if I'm
describing like on the axis like the
scale right the scale is not about like
1 I 2 I 3 on the scale is the Y number
and the y number is a real number so
that 5 that I put there is the marking
on the axis as opposed to the
coordinates of the points that make
sense
it's similar to the fact that if I were
doing a Cartesian axis you could just as
equally say this point I'm just gonna
label it like that right or
alternatively I could say
that and those are but sure you're
talking about very slightly different
things you're either saying what are the
coordinates of the theme or where are
you on the axis and they're not exactly
the same sounding tense
oh that's a great question the reason is
completely practical which is that as
you'll see in a minute sometimes you're
going to have a heck of a lot of points
right so if you were to draw all those
vectors you're gonna be sitting in for a
while and what you draw it becomes less
meaningful because those vectors are
going to start to overlap and it becomes
a bit all right so the modulus of Zed is
always fine so I can deal with this
simply geometrically okay but you won't
always be able to do it sometimes you
must appeal to algebra so how would I do
it how about I treat this thing
algebraically if I didn't recognize it
immediately
if I want to do this algebraically I
need to know like okay five is five but
this thing here I don't have to just
write like I can write in more detail
right the boy deserves that feedback you
maybe you want to draw yourself a small
diagram to remind yourself if you have
let's just have the first quadrant
you've got some complex numbers in there
where is mod Z on this diagram where is
it is it not the interval from Z to the
origin do you agree with that right so
there's more dead okay now if you want
to find that distance then all you need
is this distance here and this distance
here right because they form a right
angle triangle okay now what are those
distances they're x and y naught X and
my Y by the way that's again this is the
number of units as opposed to the
coordinates okay so therefore if this is
just a right angle triangle then mod Z
instead of writing it like that
I can write it in terms of all X's and
Y's its Pythagoras so what would you
like me to write it's the square root of
x squared plus it's just a distance yeah
yes you mean keep in mind this is a
distance to is not I why it's a distance
so it's wine okay
alright so that's that and that's just
equal to five so now I can just push on
this a little more geometrically put it
algebraically put it in form you're more
familiar with writing it without the
square root there you know of course
that's a so but does this make sense so
I gave you an easy example to begin with
because like yeah all right cool
we recognize this this just means all
the points whose distance is always five
from the origin so you can claw that
easily but you don't always get one
that's so neat you'll get something that
might require you to push on the algebra